Sarah Raab O'Hagan has been called one
of the most creative people in business
she is known for being a reinvent er of
brands beyond her accomplishments at
Nike and Virgin Atlantic Rob O'Hagan
successfully led the turnaround of
Gatorades five billion dollar business
and helped reinvent the fitness company
Equinox she now serves as CEO of the
indoor cycling company flywheel Sports
Rob O'Hagan draws from her experiences
in her new book extreme you step up
stand out kick ass repeat yes she gives
advice on how to tap into your true
potential right become
the-best-version-of-yourself Sara Rob
o'hagan joins us at the table Sara so
good to have you here love the cover
story
take us through because in the beginning
of the book you talked about what really
kind of inspired you you were giving a
speech at a Harvard conference what
happened yeah I was giving a speech and
the young lady was reading out my bio
and it was all these great accolades
like you just read out and I started
like squirming in my chair going this
isn't the full truth and I wasn't always
this person I was very average as a
child I had some epic fails along the
way including getting fired and I was
like why are we not actually telling the
truth and I realized that our culture of
success has become one where we sort of
we just want to look at the good stuff
and we don't so much get vulnerable and
be honest about some of the point is
that that also makes us better if we
recognize absolutely and because every
successful person you speak to I'm sure
all of you would say you've been through
struggles along the way and it's
important to understand particularly as
a young person that you don't always
have the answers and you are gonna have
to take risks and fail along the way
it's gonna be okay and it's okay this I
knew I liked you Sara before I met you
when you said this I'm a big bowl over
the top laugh til you snort opinionated
don't sit on the sidelines mega
enthusiastic kind of gal and I got big
feet yeah what size shoe do you wear oh
I'm gonna live it yeah but you say
perfection is overrated you tell a great
story about how you had gotten this big
promotion and you you're going in to see
the boss the next day and you oversleep
yeah
I got it way ahead of my skis and I was
like I got promoted so I went out and
picked Ram with my friends I drank and I
overslept my alarm like and missed
literally the biggest meeting of my life
not by 10 minutes by like 3 or 3 hours
but I thought I thought God would I said
somebody my family died or yeah went to
the meeting yeah thinking okay now I'm
fired because all of those thoughts went
through my head like you instantly want
to come up with excuses and in the end I
like show up and I was like there's only
one thing to say and it's the truth no
no but listen this guy's her alarm goes
off she's supposed to get off at 9:00
she wakes up at 11:00 and it's a
two-hour drive yeah so you were way late
no yeah just a little bit so you
interview so many successful people in
this you call them extreme errs yeah did
you find that they had in common so it
was really cool that I went everything
from Condoleezza Rice to mr. cotton
who's a tattoo artist to bode well of
the skier like all sorts of different
people and they all use the same
language around how they become
successful and had all these very
similar traits and it's a like openness
to experience like super proactive in
terms of not waiting to be asked to take
an opportunity but jump in and doing it
anyway and what was really interesting
to me is they all continued to push to
the next level like just as soon as they
get really good at something they're
like I got to go to the next level I'm
gonna push again you said failure hurts
but fear is even worse totally which I
think is yes because I my personal story
I have failed so many times and I
believe that the failure is what gives
you the resilience the grittiness to go
forward and lead but does it tell you
more than success does I do you think
both of them are really important and
one of the things I talk about in the
book is like you have to understand what
blows your hair back like where are you
super in your element being your best
and that's when you've been successful
but also the failures help you refine to
figure out where that place is
and don't make yourself obsolete yeah
yeah about that regardless of your age
you said yeah everybody has something to
offer absolutely absolutely and I I talk
at the end about like break yourself to
make yourself like
as soon as you get to the point where
you feel like you're at the top of your
game that's a good time to explore do
something new that's one of the things I
learned from definitely all the people
what are you can do with blind will why
will is the most awesome like indoor
cycling company I call that pitch
fitness for extremists because it's all
about what we have is this technology
that enables you as you're riding to see
your score on a board and like to
compare your results to yourself and so
where this is the beginning of how we
can take back technology to all sorts of
other places to allow lots of other
people to participate in flywheel thank
you for coming thank you yeah Rob
O'Hagan remember that name the name of
the book by the way it's called extreme
you she said we all have some extremity
in us somewhere sometimes you gotta dig
deep it's on sale right now wherever you
like to buy your books